one of my fondest childhood memories is
my dad taking us outside to burn a chunk
of sulfur that day my sister and I for
the first time in our lives got to
breathe in the toxic fumes of sulfur
dioxide it smelled terrible and I mean
terrible burning sulfur smells so bad
and is so irritating it's used to
describe hell itself when the Bible
talks about fire and brimstone Brimstone
is an archaic word for sulfur but take a
look at molten sulfur it's beautiful
sulfur dioxide is not the most dangerous
gas in the world you get a whiff every
time you light a match but in large
quantities it can be pretty hazardous so
don't do this at
home man the sense memories that brings
back are incredible it smells like
family childhood Eternal anguish and
separation from God and rotten eggs PE
you